empty calories hey what's going on
everybody I'm Sean Evans and Nellie Lee
and you're watching empty calories the
show that puts all the food stuff that
you don't have time for in one nice
clean bucket Jackson roll some clips so
here we have a woman chugging a gas
station flask of Henny like the chicks
unite and that guy's just been stressed
I keep the girl
alright so the mean says love at first
sight did that look like love to you or
did that look like concern you see a
dude do this yeah is that a hot not a
hot thing that is not a hot thing you
see a girl do it yeah I would probably
be the height man dude dude you know I
would do that a lot of policy
it's like rule cards give to the world
turning bottleservice you a competitive
sport there is like not even any words
for this it is low-key kind of a
superpower but yeah she's not that far
away
totaling from being able to limbo
underneath a locked door and then ready
time dam up like it wasn't a saint
limbo vids are all over the place now
everywhere I look I see a new limbo
[ __ ] okay that's the best limbo girl
ever well you heard it here first on
oven competition down the hatch but
first off shout out to the camera
operator yeah because he kept the kid in
frame yeah even though he might be dead
yeah and then even as the house catches
on fire yeah he keeps it all in frame
well I've seen lots of dudes set
themselves on fire
why for seemingly no other reason why
time to draw attention to themselves
online you have you know like a cinnamon
challenge oh that's kind of cute that's
kind of fun yeah and then you got kids
at the University of Iowa now take in
lighter flyer shatter shot glasses and
then just set in the whole place on fire
and I feel like these sorts of stunts
have been ratcheted up to the point
where people are just going to regularly
are dying trying to get their Instagram
followers up and now a very special
moment you know him from his subway
cookie throw you know him from his
Burger King disc his name is fat boy ssv
and he's here at empty calories to
perform a song about his McDonald's
order along with accompaniment from beat
boxing legend Chesney's snow here he is
fat boy SSG they said boy subway says
see this how old am i Mickey D's to help
my baby let me get a nice tub it quick
what is called a gravity I like my
father cookie I'll never email budget
I want a Big Mac that's a sauce with
ketchup and everything right your old
fat bill but I wanna apple plot extra
cinnamon I'm always in making keep
spinnin business I want to mix Bobby
[ __ ] extra Eminem and if it ain't by
the manager I'm into him
hey let me get an i7 300 yes yeah let me
get an i7 through the whole male just a
bell right here I don't give us too much
on my chain and my whole milk bucket
died yeah I don't brought that item I'm
healthy thank you let me get that I
ordered wait that was the order let me
get that thank you
we're loving it what about what's uh
what's the what's the stoner snack this
week with a crime tonight accused of
handing out THC lace cookies at a local
church sickening some church members in
the process yeah I mean okay yeah okay
we closed their investigation led them
to cookie and then why'd you do that
oh no she didn't need to do we all know
what we all know what I could've brought
it out really nicely next to her
led them to cookie cookie pieces what I
said involved in human trafficking right
handing out cookies was part of his
Sunday ritual he'd been doing it for
years but dispatch tested positive for
THC what was his purpose if you think
about it for a long time was there a
master plan did he do this as revenge
did he think he was going to get found
out did he want to make people sick
or maybe you just super chill and wanted
to bring some weed back you know and
like you know was just kind of a cool
dude that's a wrap for empty calories
episode four
shoutout to beat boxing legend Chesney
snow and of course Fat Boy SOT the again
next Tuesday 11:00 a.m. I'll order to
fish for lives but uh red onions and
leaf lettuce 20 piece chicken mutton I
ordered two Big Mac now they got the
grand Mac not order two grand max or the
sweet tea with limits to apple pies in a
mixed load